Now that we've learned the basic
idea of a decision tree model,
let's build out one over in AlterX.
What we're going to start with
is the exact same input data,
a select tool, plus create samples.
What I'm going to do next Is I'm
going to bring in a decision tree tool
which is found in our
predictive category.
The first thing I want to do
is simply name the model.
I'm going to simply call it,
DT_Redeemer.
I'm then going to select what
field am I trying to target.
Which is going to be
that redeemer field.
And then the next thing I'm going to
do is select my different predicted
variables which will be all
the one's besides customer key,
first name, last name,
and the redeemer fields.
And some of the different model
customization options are found in this
tab where the first
thing that we can look
at is the minimum number of records
needed to allow for a split.
So, what this means is the smaller
number that we choose here,
the more splits that we're going to
have in our decision tree.
And the same thing for
the minimum number for a terminal
note which is the next option.
If we choose this number to go down,
what we're going to have
simply more terminal nodes.
These last few items
are definitely more advanced, and
we're going to just keep
them simply by default.
If you'd like read more on them,
please just refer over to the reading
notes right below this section.
So before I kick off this workflow,
what I'm going to do is put browse
tools after the R and I outputs.
And we're going to examine
them in the next section.